depuis le début du mois d'août la forêt
amazonienne est ravagée par des
incendies d'une ampleur inédite
la forêt amazonienne s'étend sur une
vaste zone de 550 millions d'hectares
soit un peu plus de 8 fois la france
elle englobe une partie du brésil et des
pays limitrophes
[Musique]
lé feu en amazonie ont plusieurs causes
notamment le changement climatique la
sécheresse mais ils sont surtout
d'origine humaine c'est donc des grands
industriels des paysans des
multinationales surtout qui brûlent des
parties entières des parcelles entières
de forêt pour nettoyer c'est à dire pour
faire place nette
et pour en faire des terres dédiées à la
culture notamment du soja et ou alors
dédiée à l'élevage bovin ces feux ils
ont aussi pour pour cause la
déforestation
c'est une des causes principales au
brésil il faut savoir que la
déforestation elle est quatre fois plus
supérieur au mois de juillet 2019
commode juillet 2018
donc c'est vraiment des chiffres qui
sont vraiment impressionnants et la
déforestation à la plusieurs objectifs
d'abord on enlève le bois dans le but de
le vendre ensuite d'en faire du bois de
chauffage ou de la pâte à papier
ensuite on peut une fois que les terres
sont nettoyés donc brûlé on peut faire
de la culture du soja
le brésil est le principal exportateur
de soja direction notamment de la chine
majoritairement mais aussi de l'europe
la france en importent 4 milliards de
tonnes par an passé colossal notamment
pour nourrir ses bovins et la situation
ne s'est pas améliorée avec l'élection
d'un nouveau président au brésil en
octobre 2018
terrebonne sonar où il est ouvertement
climato sceptiques
il s'en est jamais caché ne crois
absolument pas au reste du réchauffement
climatique dans son programme dans ses
annonces
il a fait plusieurs déclarations chocs
notamment il
il veut construire une autoroute tout le
long de la deûle amazonie qui traverse
l'amazonie brésilienne dans le but de
relier toutes les tous les centres
industriels des multinationales des
choses comme ça qui opèrent dans cette
zone dans cette forêt tropicale lui son
objectif principal c'est de rendre
l'amazonie rentable alors s'il n'est pas
le principal responsable parce qu'on
sait que depuis les années soixante dix
la déforestation à un niveau industriel
c'est chalon chaque année de plus en
plus mais ma rousseff et michel temer
ses deux prédécesseurs avaient déjà
favorisé la déforestation lui sa base
électorale c'est vraiment laid
campesinos les grands industriels les
paysans notamment dans le nord du brésil
et il doit leur rendre des comptes et
c'est pour ça qui fait de nombreuses
déclarations chocs et de nombreuses
mesures en leur faveur
malgré les avertissements de la
communauté internationale et
scientifique
la forêt amazonienne abrite plus de 2
millions de kilomètres carrés de zones
protégées et une biodiversité unique au
monde
un quart des espèces mondiales y sont
présentes en raison de son importante
surface boisée qui permet de fixer le
co2 la jungle amazonienne est surnommé
le poumon vert de la planète
je considère que l'expression poumon
vert de la planète est intéressant parce
qu'il fait appel à une fonction vitale
et en fait on est très loin du système
de fonctionnement humain et le bilan de
fonctionnement de la forêt amazonienne
par la photosynthèse
elle fixe du carbone et rejette de
l'oxygène mais par sa respiration et par
sa dégradation elle prend de l'oxygène
et rejettent du gaz carbonique soit un
gaz à effet de serre donc le bilan
théoriquement est neutre en fait ce qui
se passe c'est si on détruit la forêt
amazonienne
là on va relâcher milliards de tonnes de
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
y'a vraiment il faut considérer le
fonctionnement global de la forêt et ce
fonctionnement il est fondé sur des
interactions sur des niches écologiques
sur des échanges de nutriments entre les
différentes espèces
il faut bien voir conditions des
échelles de temps différentes la
biomasse
une fois brûlé elle se reconstitue à
l'échelle de plusieurs dizaines d'années
parfois d'un siècle et c'est un
processus quand même relativement rapide
alors que la biodiversité elle retrouver
la biodiversité initial c'est un
processus extrêmement lent qui peut
mettre plusieurs siècles
[Musique]
il ya 148 terres indigènes qui sont
intéressés peuvent donc il ya une perte
de savoir les pertes de pratiquer une
perte de possibilités de transmission de
ces ensembles culturels extrêmement
riche qui risque de se produire
on est dans un engrenage de dégradation
qui doit être stoppée mais théoriquement
la forêt amazonienne si ces dégradations
se poursuivre elle elle peut disparaître
il ya déjà 7 185 mille kilomètres carrés
soit près de 20 % de sa surface
principalement concentré sur sa borne
lui reste et sud qui ont été transformés
en monoculture en pâturage en formation
dégradée mais il ya une question
extrêmement importante c'est ce qu'on
appelle celle du tippingpoint c'est à
dire en d'autres termes ce serait celle
du non retour
jusqu'où peut-on déboisé des fléché
brûler la forêt amazonienne
il a été estimé en
2004 scientifiques brésiliens et nord
américains ont estimé que ce point de
non-retour se situer à environ 40% de la
surface forestière
aujourd'hui quatre ans plus tard ces
mêmes scientifiques estime le
tippingpoint se situe à 20% de
dépositions de 20%
on l'a masoni n'est pas la seule région
touchée par les incendies
chaque année 13 millions d'hectares de
forêts disparaissent dans le monde lors
outre la amazonie il ya trois autres
gros paul incendiaires actuellement dans
le monde
on le voit bien sur les images de la
nasa qui à l'amazone il y à l'afrique
centrale notamment en bis et mozambique
qui sont très touchés il ya la sibérie
est la toundra qui est très touchée et
l'asie du sud est avec l'indonésie et la
malaisie avec la forêt de bornéo qui est
particulièrement impacté par ces feux de
forêt faut pas tomber dans les
raccourcis les causes sont différentes
entre ses quatre pôles incendiaires en
afrique centrale c'est un peu différent
c'est des petits paysans notamment
surtout qu'ils pratiquent la culture du
brûlis c'est une culture ancestrale qui
datent des millénaires et qui a pour but
donc de nettoyer la forêt mais dans le
but de rendre la terre plus fertile
alors ça provoque des feux gigantesque
qui sont devenus hors de contrôle avec
le changement climatique actuellement en
sibérie c'est aussi différent il y
aurait visiblement une bonne partie de
feu d'origine criminelle
et ça serait alimenté aussi par le
réchauffement climatique actuellement on
est dans une zone où il fait entre +5 et
plus lui degrés par rapport aux moyennes
saisonnières et ses feux sont devenus
complètement hors de contrôle 12
millions d'hectares ont été brûlées
depuis janvier et en en asie du sud-est
notamment en indonésie l'aller
c'est pareil c'est des grands groupes
qui brûlent vraiment la forêt de bornéo
dans le but là c'est pour faire du
caoutchouc et de l'huile de palme et qui
est massivement exporté en europe
notamment
si rien n'est fait pour endiguer de
telles catastrophes des incendies de la
forêt amazonienne en 2019 pourrait bien
causer sa disparition il serait alors le
début d'un phénomène planétaire
[Musique]